you think I want Sophia Falcone knocking
on my
door she is the hangman Sophia Falcone
is the hanged man and in Batman he was
thrown off the roof and um when um Grant
Morrison was writing in his book super
Gods he wrote that that specific scene
when he threw him off and he grabbed him
by his left foot was the hanged man of
the tarot this is the last movie that
Heath Ledger was
in hang ah yeah what are the chances of
that that Keith Ledger thrown off the
roof is literally the hanged man of the
tarot card and in the very next movie he
dies in this movie playing this part and
he's also the hanged man here comes this
woman who clearly is inane she's the
hangman warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children viewer discretion is advised in
taking a look at some of these things
that have been um nominated for best
actor penguin was one that popped up and
uh you guys know anything about this
about the TV show the show yeah I've
watched the trailers that's about it
okay I know it's a continuation of the
Batman
moviee same actors same so they are
spinning off the character the Penguin
and um we talked about this a little bit
um when we did the replacement God so I
want to show you a couple of things here
but the penguin um was nominated for
best actor here's a little clip of that
and the Golden Globe goes
to the
penguin make the
cut no one to thank on this one I did it
all by
myself just a raw paired away
performance
um it's pretty amazing when you actually
see the amount of makeup and
transformation that he went through it
actually is pretty amazing the penguin
does not look like that guy no not at
all in fact he sat for 4 hours in the
chair every single time he put this suit
on but he transformed this character and
what what I found that was very
interesting and and disturbing about
this as well is um a lot of people that
like it or are drawn to it are drawn to
it because of its evil and dark M
character M and the Penguin was kind of
a dark character to begin with but um
listen to what even Colin frell says
himself about the writing in the
character but this I knew was going to
get it obviously darker trauma torture
yeah dark dark dark character like dark
really dark like darker than I would
have thought having done even the five
or six scenes in the film you're going
to do everything I
say or else I'll M you and uh anyone you
care about you got it yeah
so how many times did he say this is a
dark character a lot it's really dark in
dark dark dark right dark why why are
people so drawn to this I mean to start
off with we got penguin as as the enemy
of an already dark hero right in a dark
place Gotham City right got to be the
darkest Town Place in the DC Universe
yeah I think it's I think it's the Human
Condition from sin I'm sitting here
thinking of a text that's in Luke it
says this is a part of Jesus mission to
give light to those who sit in darkness
in the shadow of death to guide our feet
in the way of peace and really that's
that's the Human Condition because of
sin we're all in darkness and under the
shadow of death and and people love this
it's like it's like the more darker
content that's coming out the the more
they are encouraged by it let me read to
you a couple of things um Reddit very
interesting as people are are talking
about this but read the headline right
here Keith the penguin is exactly the
kind of villain story we need more of
why this so dark and it's so evil go
ahead Felipe and read what it's
highlighted here and like a fallen angel
from the heavens Here Comes The Penguin
give us some delicious food finally it
is tasty but poisoned I mean look at
that right one way to describe it right
they're not even shying away like look
this is like a fallen angel giving you a
piece of poison food to eat well that's
called Satan in the Garden of Eden right
yeah um but look at what people are
saying about this he's some sort of
sympathetic villain I love to see a
character who's very human while being a
horrible monster that's actually
responsible for the majority of things
that go bad in his life and then further
on look at what he says right here I was
worried at a few points that they were
going to make him seem like he was
actually not all that bad nope he's as
bad as you think wow like this is what
they like about it huh that there's not
an explanation that there's not some
sort of reason that he's bad that
because he was grown up in his childhood
or whatever he's not a Broken Hero he's
just bad he's bad and he's really bad
and that's what they love about this
look at this comment right here yeah
amazing they totally trick you into
thinking that he's going to be not that
bad but he is that bad um but he
actively chooses to be we can totally
understand why he does it he's fully in
control of his own evil and that's
what's just so interesting to me you see
when people can understand why the
villain does
it in their mind they're not the villain
anymore right right right that's when
they become favored and it and it
shouldn't be surprising we kind of saw
the writing on the wall several years
ago when Hollywood started putting out
rated R superhero films and you saw the
people's response you know Deadpool was
the first Deadpool was an $80 million
project 80 million that's not a lot for
a Hollywood film right sometimes they
400 million it made over $800 million
wow and the second one made over $800
million yeah and now everyone's just bad
worse terrible and then you know after
Deadpool came the rated R Wolverine and
people are like we want spawn you know
rated R and they would just you saw
people's reaction we want more violence
more sexual gratuiti more foul language
like Deadpool it was like a you know
yeah curse word every minute or
something in the whole thing I think
there's a reason for this and I think
that's why we're seeing more attraction
to this but I want to bring you back um
we brought this up in the replacement
Gods this an oldie but goody um way back
in Burton's um uh second Batman called
Batman Returns this is right after the
um film credits Ru so as you can see
right here Batman Returns is put on the
screen and they're showing you an
imagery of where the penguin actually
comes from parents take a basket throw
the basket in the river and here's where
the P penguin's backstory begins now the
penguin um there was a book that was
written by David Hughes it's yeah comic
books they were kind of looking at where
are all these Inspirations coming from
and stuff like that so when David
hughes's book um go ahead and read that
Keith says is inspired by Moses's
parallels of stricks prologue in which
baby penguin is bundled in a basket and
thrown in the river where he floats
helpless till he's saved and
subsequently raised by Gotham's sewer
denisons in which penguin's master plan
is to kill the firstborn sons of Gotham
City so who was giving the decree that
the firstborn Sons would die Pharaoh
that was Pharaoh but it came through
Moses's mouth right and that was part of
the story line that was played in this
story right here is the Penguin um
talking about the forborn sons of
Gotham it's time these are the names of
the firstborn sons of Gotham CI just
like I was
and like me a terrible fate waits for
them all right so let me ask you this
question is Moses a a good guy or bad
guy Moses is a good guy AAL hero in fact
the Bible describes him as a Christ type
so this is very interesting to me that
the Batman world is placing a Moses
parallel a Christ type parallel on on a
character that they are literally
ascribing sheer evil to yeah PL playing
both parts Moses part and Pharaoh's part
right that's kind of Flipping The
Narrative upside down right here and in
Tim Burton's um um story when they're
showing you where the penguin actually
came from what day is the Penguin born
on Yeah Christmas day is wealthy family
yes very interesting I mean we're
assuming Christmas day it's around
Christmas time yes and it says 33 years
later is when the story of this Batman
particularly takes place and in this
particular story penguin dies I was
about to ask does he die he dies so
that's quite a coincidence yeah here we
go like here's a Christ type Moses
parallel born technically supposedly on
Christmas Day and dies 33 years later
who are they telling you that this
character actually is 33 is such a
specific number right I know it's not
like 25 yeah it's like just say 40 years
later 30 years or something right three
decades later I don't know the other
thing though is it it you know when
they're flipping that model they're also
what are they saying about the parents
yeah interesting you know the parents
are the ones that sold him down the
river and and if he's supposed to be
this Christ type in the Moses Story the
parents did it to save him they're not
doing it to save him they're doing it to
get rid of him interesting right and the
parents are are like if Moses is this
Christ type then it's like the parents
are like this type of God interesting
and so God is doesn't want anything have
to do with you just get rid of them it's
really this confusion flipping the model
upside down on its head but I want to
point something out that that I caught
in the new trailer to The Penguin which
I thought was really interesting um and
we'll talk about this in a second you
think I want Sophia Falone knocking on
my
door she is the hangman Sophia Falcone
is the hanged
man where do we see that have you ever
seen this before yeah the hanged man
actually comes up a little bit in some
of the Batman's stories Grant Morrison
he wrote for Superman he often talked
about um Batman and here he was writing
um about in his book called Super Goods
he was writing about where some of these
stories get their inspiration from and
there is a lot of tarot meanings and the
story of Batman um would have heavy
tarot meanings in it and I thought that
was really interesting that um Grant
Morrison wrote that he he he's basically
saying look Crowley Yung who are those
guys Keith not very nice people right Al
Crowley's one of the most evil people he
was a he was essentially a Satanist and
Carl Young atheist atheist he's a modern
father for gnosticism philosopher type a
lot of Hollywood loves this kind of
stuff but um there is a heavy amount of
tarot involved in the story now the
hanged man of the Taro card means to
yield suspend surrender sacrifice
non-action submission and in between now
this is some sort of
subverted version of a Christ type MH so
obviously tarot is not a good thing but
this is what a hanged man is and we saw
the hanged man pop up in a movie called
The Imaginarium of Dr panassus in which
um Heath Ledger who played The Joker
Joker another villain yes and in that
Batman he was thrown off the roof and um
when um Grant Morris was writing in his
book super Gods he wrote that that
specific scene when he threw him off and
he grabbed him by his left foot was the
hanged man of the tarot and that scene
was copied after tarot and I found it
really interesting that that was the
last this is the last movie that Heath
Ledger was in a lot of people know him
for his Batman role but this was the
actual last one with thec in it yeah
look at all this ult stuff that's in
this movie but in this particular movie
it's very interesting that they uh
literally showed you the hanged
man
hang yeah what are the chances of that
that Keith Ledger thrown off the roof is
literally the hanged man of the tarot
card and in the very next movie he dies
in this movie playing this part and he's
also the hanged man it's weird he's the
sacrifice yeah I mean d there's a lot of
weird things that that go on in mov M
like this but doesn't that make it
pretty interesting when they're talking
about the hanged man in the new
penguin to me that's like they're
messing around with evil on a different
scale than what I think people are just
like this is just meaningless you know
pretend yeah no reason to really work
that in no not at all no let me ask you
something is this Sophia character is
she on the penguin side or she
ised I think she's a competing villain
Falone is a a villain in the Batman Saga
yes so it's like a bunch of evil people
and you know they're calling her the
hanged man which is really interesting
but fascinating you know her name Sophia
Greek for wisdom you know knowledge you
know so it speaks to those those themes
as well that are that are often
intertwined in these stories yeah very
Gnostic we can we can see that is again
putting
Jesus as the enemy right as we can see
it a pattern with every other movie the
wisdom right the the hangman the
sacrifice MH all of that with every
movie that we see it's always like that
MH Sophia was um in gnosticism was
basically like the uh enlightened and en
weakened one so it is interesting that
they added that name in this and that's
the role that she's kind of playing
Romans 12 21 sayso not be overcome by
evil but overcome evil with good amen
and I think it's it's it's interesting
that our society is gravitating towards
like like heralding and
awarding the more evil it can get you
know what I mean like like now you watch
what some of this penguin's version is
and you go back to like Tim Burton Tim
Burton's look like Child's Play oh yeah
compared to what we're seeing today yeah
what is your kids going to view as this
if you watch the progression especially
of the Joker it just got like more evil
more evil more evil more evil every
movie like the Gerald let one was like
terrifying yeah it's just sick and dis
disgusting and Heath Ledger he um you
know there was this uh quote I think
from Jack Nicholas before he died he
told him Jack Nicholas said I told him
not to do it yep like to play the part
of take cuz Jack nson had taken the role
of the Joker in Michael Keaton you know
in Tim Burton's Batman Michael Keaton
and yeah he told him not to do it and
and he was like really tortured I think
he sat in rooms that were like totally
dark for two years he locked himself in
a room had a book that he would just
write the most wicked things that his
mind could come up with in it he was a
method actor yeah yeah really messed him
up yeah so you know the Bible has a lot
of good advice for us um don't focus on
all this evil there's no reason why we
as Christians should be watching these
things because look at what it says
about the end of time he will render
each one according to his works and
those who by patience in well-doing seek
for Glory and Honor and immortality he
will give eternal life if that's our
focus is really to to be focused on the
good wholesome beautiful things of life
and and to to seek eternal life we need
to be focused on a holy
existence but look at what happens if
you don't but those who are self-seeking
and do not obey the truth but obey
unrighteousness there will be wrath and
fury nobody wants that nobody wants that
and it's like we're coming into an
Endtime scenario where if you I mean
this this verse is a well-known verse of
what's happening in the end of time and
when you read this this this is probably
the script right here for this whole
television show right but understand
this that in the last days there will
become time for difficulty for people
will be lovers of self lovers of money
proud arrogant abusive disobedient to
their parents ungrateful Unholy
heartless unappeasable slanderous
without self-control brutal and not
loving good treacherous Reckless swollen
with conceit lovers of pleasure rather
than lovers of God having the appearance
of godliness but denying its power and
Keith what does it tell us to do with
such people says avoid them avoid them
yeah so should we avoid movies with
these things in them where it's
glorifying people like that as well I
think we should avoid them I mean that
makes sense yeah here's one to avoid
with the um you know in in Genesis I
think it's in chapter six you know God
gives a description of the earth during
that time and he says the thoughts of
their hearts were only evil
continually that's what we're headed
towards the Bible says Jesus the words
of you know he talks about it being like
the days of Noah in the end of in the
end of time so it it's clearly a
depiction of of what we're like you know
that kind of those kind of films those
kind of shows it's a depiction of what
this world is like but the Bible tells
us don't have anything to do with that
that's right one of the best things that
we can do as Christians is the sil
protest right you know we get questions
all the time about movies like this and
it surprises me actually it doesn't
surprise me anymore when people in the
comment section I'm sure you're going to
see in the comment section Christians
defending this oh whatever you know this
is just you know your guys's opinion and
this doesn't matter I'm not going to
actually go out and do those things but
why would we want to watch someone else
do them and and our discussions of this
is not to do a review like what we're
doing is not to like oh yeah let's
review this one this is not to to do
that at all our discussions are based on
like look there's things in here you may
or may not be seen you need to be aware
of you need to compare that with your
Bible and the Bible says turn away from
all that stuff and fill your life with
better things it's not about reviewing
it I mean this is this is a call to
action yep yeah the Bible says that by
beholding we become changed yep right if
we keep beholding these things right
movie after movie and you know they're
all about villains now Venom Loki uh
Deadpool
penguin we become changed whether we
like it or not that's how we were
created that's why you should be
beholding God facing the book right
that's that's what God has called us to
do really as you can see from the
beginning of this conversation people
that are um you know
hungering and thirsting for this kind of
stuff it just will get darker and darker
and darker and more and more evil and
wicked but uh the Bible tells us to
hunger and thirst after righteousness
and that's what we actually hope you
guys are gaining from our uh exposes on
these kind of things um but we want to
know your thoughts what do you think
give us uh give us what you think in the
description or the the comment section
below and give this video a thumbs up
share with somebody that you might think
would benefit from this pray for our
ministry and check out some of our other
material um today we took some clips
from um something called the replacement
Gods we have a whole video um about the
Batman Superman where some of those
Origins come from so check that out
we'll see you guys on the next one
[Music]
St